one of my co-workers went to a
conference in Greece and came back with
the present of something which is very
old from 400 years BC or even earlier
but I never seen before it's called the
Pythagoras cup and it has this strange
bit sticking up in the middle and the
story is that this cup was invented by
Pythagoras the one that worked on
right-angled triangles he invented it so
when he gave his students wine they all
got the same amount and if somebody was
greedy that student got his comeuppance
it behaves normally until you get this
gold ring here the one I'm running my
finger round not the one up here and if
you fill it above that that somewhere
between these two suddenly all the
liquid in the glass drains out and
through a hole in the bottom of course
you can't see what's happening here so I
rushed off and bought a glass one so you
can see what's happening I asked Neal to
demonstrate it you pour in the water
imagine it's wine but if it was weighing
you couldn't see inside and as the level
of the wine Rises suddenly if you're too
greedy it all ripples out
and it siphons out through the little
tube in the center
the way it works is that inside here
there is a YouTube which has a small
opening at the bottom and as the liquid
rises the u-tube fills up and when it
gets to the top it siphons round and
sucks the water out I was really excited
about this and then when I was driving
home I wondered what would happen if you
filled it with mercury mercury is a very
dense liquid so I persuaded Neil to fill
it with mercury and it works just as
well with motoring
and what is interesting is that when you
do it with water the water on our glass
pythagoras cup dribbles out at a sort of
angle because water so-called wets glass
it sticks to the glass but with mercury
because it is denser and it doesn't wet
glass we go straight down and makes
quite a sort of spectacular pattern in
the bottom of the dish I then had a
slightly strange idea I wondered what
would have happened if you put just the
little mercury in and then filled the
rest with water and I predicted because
water is much less dense than mercury
that in fact you could fill the cup
right to the top so Neil obligingly
tried it even though he was meant to be
going on the holiday and it works you
can feel the Pythagoras Cup right to the
top if you put a bit of motor at the
bottom so what is happening is that the
weight of the water is just not enough
to force the mercury up inside the
siphon if you fill it completely with
mercury you have enough weight pushing
down to make the siphon work so the
upshot is that if Pythagoras his
students had been clever they could have
put some mercury in the bottom of the
cup and filled it right to the top the
downside of course is that they would
have poisoned themselves
there were quite nice crystals that you
could see formed and the surface of the
metal and there was this great length of
mercury at the bottom solid but Neal had
quite lots of difficulty getting it out
at the end and it began to melt and so
on but that wasn't part of the
experiment